Cuba vive una nueva Revolución esta vez
en su código de familia aprobado en
referendo en septiembre cambió la vida
de Pedro Rafael Delgado de 56 años y de
Adolfo López de 62 años por fin pudieron
casarse siempre viví
con ese rechazo con ese dolor de que tus
propias familias y fuera los que te
censuraran en octubre Se realizaron 75
matrimonios entre personas del mismo
sexo son más del 2% del total de bodas
en Estados Unidos los hogares del mismo
sexo representan el 1,5 pero activistas
consideran que todavía hay camino por
recorrer la lucha también es cultural
una vez aprobada la ley Hay que seguir
trabajando con las mentalidades para que
los prejuicios sean poco a poco
desmontados la nueva ley también cambió
la vida de Ariana mederos está
estudiante de Medicina pensó que nunca
podría desarrollar su carrera cuando
hace unos años empezó su transición
la sociedad tiene un poco de avance que
yo lo he visto bastante marcado porque
las personas hoy como tal no se dirigen
a una persona trans como lo hacían antes
mirando sobre el ojo sobre el hombro el
referendo contó con gran publicidad y
apoyo mediático la mitad de 11 millones
de cubanos participaron en la discusión
del proyecto y tras su aprobación Cuba
se sitúa en la vanguardia de derechos
sociales emprendida antes en Argentina
Brasil Chile y Colombia